[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast here are our top stories this
morning
[Music]
happy new year london puts on a smaller
than usual celebration to mark the first
moments of 2022
and it's a quietest start to the year in
the rest of the uk's covered
restrictions crashed the party
alongside the celebrities the new year
honours are dominated by scientists and
volunteers who led the response to the
kovid 19 pandemic
farewell to a peacemaker the funeral of
archbishop desmond tutu takes place in
south africa
standing room only for the first time in
30 years some premier league fans won't
have to sit to watch matches
your weather it'll be an exceptionally
mild start to the new year but also
rather wet and windy at times
and at quarter two we'll take a look at
papers with the journalists and
broadcaster podesha and the entrepreneur
kate castle
[Music]
hello there very good morning and happy
new year you've done very well to join
us now across the uk it was a very
different start to 2022 depending on
where you live in england pubs and
nightclubs were open for the new year
while in scotland wales and northern
ireland covered restrictions meant for
many it was a much quieter night despite
warnings for people to stay away
thousands turned out for the
celebrations in central london as
caterina vitotsy now reports
it's the reliable sound of new year and
after many more months of covert
uncertainty big ben sounded incredibly
comforting
the famous clock open again after four
years of renovations kicked off a
display the london mayor described as
spectacular
but this was a different sort of london
show planned for tv the location wasn't
made public and officials asked people
to stay home
some though did gather around
traditional landmarks by the river
thames hoping to see something but the
big display was further out of the
city's center and many here didn't see
much
it's only we saw this morning it said
that the fireworks were back on tonight
and they'd allowed it so you expected
the normal new year's eve
things so it's a little bit of a let
down but it's nice to still be out and
be able to do it on this part of the
river thames where traditionally the
fireworks display is held there was a
brief but beautiful display that offered
a tantalizing glimpse into what might
come in 2022 and new year's eve where
perhaps things might feel a little bit
more like normal
london's bars clubs and restaurants were
open too
no covert restrictions here but still
places not as packed as you'd expect for
new year's eve
it was certainly busier though than
edinburgh where official hog money
celebrations were cancelled and big
events curtailed
a few lonely pipers couldn't really lift
the mood
that task left to london
the english capital bringing in 2022
not back to normal by any means but
still with plenty of sparkle
katherine patosi sky news in london
while the party was going on in england
it was a more subdued night across the
rest of the uk covered restrictions
meant nightclubs were shut while many
pubs decided to close early but for some
a trip across the border from wales to
england meant the celebrations could
take place after all as dan whitehead
reports
at the stroke of midnight the welsh
capital was all but empty
for a second year in a row no crowds and
no revellers pouring out of nightclubs
they were forced to close yet again
in the bars and pubs that were open
there was little trade with the rule of
six back and table service only i was
hoping there'd be more people than what
it was to be fair for more of an
atmosphere
and i was hoping a bit of clubs
obviously just turned 18
but you know it's what it is it's not
the right atmosphere
at all it's just way too quiet
as omicron cases spread the welsh
government had taken a tougher approach
to new year celebrations
for some it made business impossible
the pub in newport had planned a big
glitter ball party but in the end they
decided to cancel with the restrictions
we've decided it's really not fair on
the staff to ask customers not to mingle
at midnight because they're just it's
understandable people will want to say
happy new year to their friends and it's
not fair on my staff to be the ones to
have the police but they're not allowed
to do that so we've decided to close
with new year plans curtailed some
decided to leave the country in search
of a good night
because as soon as you get to the other
side of the seven crossing in england
there are of course fewer restrictions
the nightclubs are all open and there's
no limit to the number of people that
you can meet up with
trains from swansea cardiff and newport
arriving in bristol were full of welsh
partygoers we just like sat in a pub and
not being able to dance and like who
wants to just sit down
and it was like
a table of six you can't mix with anyone
i don't know and i i personally don't
think it makes much sense that like you
only have to cross a bridge and the
rules are completely different swansea
there's no clubs
pubs up until 12 tables six in bristol
we can do we want
while there were some fireworks in wales
most chose to stay at home
as the first minister warns of some
tough weeks ahead
dan white had sky news in cardiff
uh so skies malaya vessellinovich is in
central london for us where the
traditional new year's day parade is
going to take place a little bit later
on today a very happy new year to you
millennia what can we expect
happy new year to you too well this
parade has been held in central london
since the late
1980s normally thousands of people line
up along the route it's very different
this year there's going to be about 600
ticket spectators right here behind me
containing this space in central london
but still organizers promise it's going
to be a great show with performers from
around the world with dance troops
marching bands and musical acts and it
comes after a night of slightly more
subdued celebrations as we've heard even
in england where there are no
restrictions on gathering it's still not
the new year's eve that we've had from
the years past it seems that some people
still cautious decided to stay at home
even though they didn't have to now the
message from the government is to go out
and enjoy yourself you can do that but
to be cautious to be careful take a
lateral flow test if you can get your
hands on one that is but still here
excitement building up we can hear the
performance uh rehearsing so it's all uh
due to kickoff at about one o'clock this
afternoon
okay uh we'll see how things progress
throughout the day melania thank you
very much for now and of course around
the world new year celebrations have
been taking place let's have a look at
some of the highlights just after five
o'clock this morning uk time 2022 began
in new york restrictions meant fewer
people than normal were allowed into
times square but 15 000 revelers were
there to welcome in the new year
at around a.m uk time brazil saw in the
new year with celebrations and fireworks
on kobe cabana beach in rio de janeiro
up until last week the city's mayor had
threatened to cancel the main
celebrations because of concerns over
the spread of kovid 19 but it did go
ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a similar picture elsewhere in
europe as crowds of people flocked to
watch the new year's celebrations in
madrid however authorities only allowed
7 000 people into the puerto del sol to
watch as opposed to the usual number
around 20 000
now this is impressive two guinness
world records were set by new year
celebrations in the united arab emirates
officials in rasal kamar organized the
highest drone fireworks display ever the
event almost sorry the event also saw
the most number of drones ever taking
part in the single display with more
than 500 flying over the arabian gulf
just wait for it here it comes
oh you've missed it
the drones all said happy new year it's
fantastic we'll show you a little bit
later now doctors and scientists who led
the fight against covid19 have been
rewarded for their work in this
morning's new year's honors there were
also awards for team gb successful
olympians and teenage tennis sensation
emma radhakani while former prime
minister tony blair is now a sir
charlotte lomas has more on who's made
the list and a warning that her report
does contain some flash photography
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a distinctive youthful feel to
this year's honors list eleven-year-old
tobias weller known as the captain in
his hometown of sheffield raised more
than
157 thousand pounds during the pandemic
he wanted to help others with cerebral
palsy and autism and says he's chuffed
to bits to be the youngest person on
record to receive the british empire
medal
my man my mum tell me about
her majesty
mcqueen the queen
i am so excited
2021 was also the year science fought
back against covid and in recognition
the medical chiefs leading the battle
have been honoured professor chris
whittie his deputy jonathan van tam and
the welsh and scottish counterparts will
all receive knighthoods
it's been such a delight to work with
chris and my colleagues in northern
ireland michael mcbride and gregor smith
up in scotland you know and it's it's
actually brought us together as chief
medical officers across the four nations
in total one in five of the new year's
honors are related to covid
including a knighthood for sky news's
trevor phillips his work with data
company web affiliates was the first to
examine the effect of covid on different
cultural and ethnic groups
we've brought
science in particular in my case data
science to bear in understanding
what
differences really mean in our society
and we saw last year that kovid really
had a differential impact according to
who you were where you came from where
you lived
kovit also brought testing times to the
world of sport in 2021 under strict
conditions the tokyo olympics finally
went ahead with team gb lifting the
spirits of the nation with some
outstanding performances those who took
gold will be honoured by the queen
including cyclists laura and jason kenny
who will receive a dame and knighthood
they're thought to be the first married
couple to be honoured at the same time
and teenage tennis sensation emma
radicanu ends the year with another
title to her growing collection after
being given an mbe
other famous british faces awarded
include actress joanna lumley who we
made a dame and after his final outing
is james bond daniel craig has been made
a companion of the order of saint
michael and saint george a special
diplomatic honor also given to his
fictional character double07
[Music]
in what has been a challenging year the
new year's honors list recognises all
those who've entertained and inspired
and led the way in uncertain times
charlotte lomas sky news
also making the news this morning at
least 500 homes are thought to have been
destroyed by large wildfires in colorado
tens of thousands of people have been
forced to flee after fires were driven
by winds of more than 100 miles an hour
at least seven people are thought to
have been injured
the archbishop of canterbury has used
his new year message to call for a
renewed fight against climate change
justin welby said world leaders must do
more to protect the planet
hundreds of millions of people are
already suffering the impacts of our
rapidly warming planet
extreme weather droughts and famines and
conflicts
intensified by competition over natural
resources
at least 12 people have been killed in a
stampede at a shrine in kashmir reports
say 13 others were injured during the
incident at the hindu shrine near jammu
city
i thought i heard a strange noise what
kind of strange noise like someone
walking slowly up creaking stairs
we don't have stairs
i know how strange is that
oh she was just so funny wasn't she and
president biden has led the tributes to
the actress and golden girl star betty
white who's died at the age of 99.
hollywood star ryan reynolds simply said
the world looks very different
now
the funeral of archbishop desmond tutu
is taking place in south africa this
morning we can take you to cape town now
kevin restrictions mean just 100 people
are expected to attend the service at st
george's cathedral
in cape town the archbishop and nobel
peace prize winner who helped end
apartheid in south africa died on sunday
he was 90 years old
and of course we'll bring you uh that
funeral uh as it begins at around eight
o'clock this morning
let's take a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
although the new year will start off
exceptionally mild things are set to
turn much colder from monday as the
winds swing round to a northerly
direction for now though it's mostly
mild and dry across britain as overnight
rain clears from northern scotland
however it will be windy in the west as
the band of rain moves across ireland
and northern ireland this narrow band of
rain will quickly move eastwards through
today with bright or sunny skies either
side it stays mild and rather windy for
most with severe gales in the far
northwest blustery showers will develop
in western scotland northern ireland and
the republic these will push further
east during the afternoon and could be
heavy at times it remains mild but
rather windy tonight especially in the
blustery far northwest there will be
further bands of showers overnight some
on the heavy side sunday will bring a
mix of sunny spells and blustery showers
which may cluster into longer spells of
rain
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
now despite his global reputation just
100 people are expected to attend the
funeral of archbishop desmond tutu in
south africa this morning covered
restrictions combined with his own
wishes mean it'll be a very simple
service while glenda wheelskit former
truth and reconciliation commissioner
with archbishop tutu joins us now from
cape town and we're just watching live
pictures from the cathedral as mourners
take their seats thank you very much for
joining us so a simple service but
rather fitting because the archbishop
said he didn't want to fuss or anything
too lavish
good morning yes and happy new year to
you
um
yes it is a very simple ceremony
even the days leading up to
the funeral today
he lay in state
in a very simple
coffin
with just a small bunch of flowers on
the coffin
and
that was his wish
that he would be buried very simply
um that the ceremony would be very
simple
with of course a religious
tone
and um
and surrounded by those who love him
as they lay him to rest
yes he even said he wanted the cheapest
coffin possible
didn't he um it's going to be a very sad
day of course for you but also the
chance to reflect on his remarkable life
how will you be remembering him as that
funeral gets underway
oh i remember him very fondly for
his deep deep sense of integrity his
deep sense of faith
believing that all of us
as his personal philosophy of ubuntu
all of us are made in the image of god
all of us are
important to each other
as we are interconnected and we are
dependent on each other and this
philosophy
was evident in everything that he did
he honored everyone
the little people as he calls him and
those who had
status and standing in communities
sorry do you carry on yes
i really really remember him for that
and the absolute wonderful
um
leadership that he portrayed during the
truth and reconciliation commission
um
he he showed us what true servant
leadership is all about
he also showed us
how to be compassionate and to deal with
those who had come to the commission
um
to tell their stories under difficult
and and and
very bravely coming to speak about the
experience of the apartheid past
we've been looking at some pictures of
him and he was this extraordinary
communicator wasn't he he had that
infectious
laugh as well but also he wasn't afraid
to pull punches when needed
absolutely
he was critical
wherever he
experienced or saw injustice and spoke
out about
injustice and
and untruths
and lies and deceit wherever he found it
both to the
past government
of apartheid government and also to the
present government where he experienced
issues of corruption
and and wrong doing
he spoke out and so he is a global icon
for peace and justice and reconciliation
yeah he was certainly very critical
wasn't he of uh the current uh political
situation and that corruption as you say
how do you think he'll be
his work will carry on in south africa
when we interacted him before
he always said that he's not going to be
here forever
and that we should be
taking up the baton that he will one day
leave behind
and i think that
although
it does seem
many times that there is not
a
strong leadership
in our country at the
at the present moment
we do also believe that there will be
those brave young men and women who will
take up the
take up the cudgels and take up the
baton and move forward
and speak out against injustice
well glenda wheelskit uh we are very
grateful for your time today former
truth and reconciliation commissioner
with archbishop desmond tutu thank you
for joining us and a happy new year on
what is a very sad day and talking about
the the current leadership president
cyril ramaphosa is expected to deliver
the main eulogy at that service in saint
george's chapel in cape town a little
bit later as you can see mourn is just
gathering in the cathedral now desmond
tutu's body has been lying in state in
the cathedral for the last few days
we'll bring that to you of course when
it starts
you're watching sky news at breakfast
coming up there won't be the usual
crowds but the boss of london's new year
parade joins us to look ahead to this
year's event
[Music]
if you're just joining us a very good
morning happy new year it is 7 34 and
you're watching sky news breakfast now a
different looking annual new year parade
takes place in london a bit later on
today concerns about kovid mean far
fewer spectators will be allowed but
organizers are still promising a
world-class event let's speak to the
executive director of the parade bob
bone morning bob a very happy new year
to you so tell us what can we expect
well first of all good morning jonathan
happy new year to you as well uh what
can we expect well as you said it's a
very very different sort of event this
year because
normally we're 10 000 participants on
the streets of the west end with around
about 600 000 live audience uh filling
the streets to watch it uh well we can't
do that this year for obvious reasons uh
but we have planned something it's going
to be pretty good uh we're really a tv
show this year with a live audience and
we're going to be in waterloo place at
one o'clock this afternoon um the
audience is all ticketed incidentally
completely sold out has been for quite a
while so don't anybody try and try and
come into it but do watch it on tv it's
uh
goes out as i said one o'clock it's on
london live it's also on live now
streaming service which can be accessed
through our website lmydp.com
we've got loads of the usual
participants in our arena-based show
this year
marching bands
samba dancers
people from carnival del pueblo all the
latin american countries represented
then we've taken the advantage uh that
we have this year of having an
arena-based uh static show of building a
stage as well into our arena so that we
can bring in some
some very very talented performers
singers and uh dancers and so on uh so
for example we've got uh voice winner
molly hocking appearing we've got uh
west end star marisha wallace appearing
and we've got indie chart topper michael
armstrong on our stage today um along
with the host of the usual things that
you expect to see in london's new year's
day parade so we're pretty sure it's
going to be a very very exciting and we
hope successful event yeah let's hope so
and the weather should be on your side
as well pretty mild isn't it for for
this time of year amazingly so yes i was
wondering whether to get the thermals
out today or not as usual and i've
pretty much decided not to actually i
think we're going to be looking at
around about 14 or 15 degrees throughout
most of the day and the best of all it
looks like it might not rain so that's
fantastic for us yeah that's key isn't
it of course tell us a bit about the
history of this event then bob well
we've been going now this will be a 36th
event on new year's day i was going to
say parade then it's not quite a parade
this year uh but 36 won we we started on
the 1st of january 1987 and we've grown
exponentially every single year right up
to 2020 when as i say we peaked with a
street audience of about 650 000 and 10
000 performers on the streets um
22 countries around the world
represented as well as uh always one of
our key things was uh getting
representation from all of london
boroughs in our london borough
competition so we invited every year
london boroughs to put a float in and
they were competing for charity prizes
and over the years we've contributed the
best part of two million pounds to local
uh london charities uh through the event
so there's that that strand of the event
plus of course there's the other strand
which is we've introduced uh london and
great britain and many parts of the
world to the wonders of american
marching bands which we never used to
see much of here before and we regularly
bring in around about 20 marching bands
from the states every year uh not this
year of course because travel
regulations don't make that possible but
we have got contributions uh from our
american friends uh that we went out and
we made little film packages of them
giving their performances in the states
which we're going to play out through
our tv show and on big screens to our
live audience
sounds good tell you what bob you're
full of beans this morning am i taking
it that you had an early night last
night yeah very very early
uh whether that's to do with age or just
the fact that i knew what was coming up
today i'm not sure but yeah i feel full
of beans right now i hope i will at one
o'clock and even more so at half past
three when we finish yeah excellent all
right well i hope it all goes well we
appreciate your time today bob bone
executive director london's new year's
day parade thanks very much
now for the first time in almost three
decades fans will be allowed to stand
while watching some premier league games
several clubs have introduced so-called
rail seating which has been approved by
safety experts all sita stadiums were
introduced of course after the
hillsborough tragedy in which 97
liverpool fans were killed our sports
correspondent tom parmenter reports
it's just an instinct for so many
football fans to get up on your feet
[Applause]
and support your team
while they should be sat down
standing
will now be permitted at selected
premier league grounds
[Applause]
of course kovid has played havoc with
the festive fixtures but the new rails
are in
and ready for their debut chelsea have
put over 12 000 of these safe standing
spaces in and it is completely different
to how people used to stand here in the
shed end at stanford bridge back in the
old days you now have one designated
spot you're being monitored very closely
and it's proven to have worked elsewhere
it's long been part of german football
to great effect
and at glasgow celtic it's worked
successfully for the past five years
[Applause]
it's all starting to go off flags are
out songs are going drums are going
liverpool fan gareth roberts was unsure
until he tried it for himself you are
standing up but you've got your space
you can't you can't fall backwards you
can't fall forwards there's no domino
effect and straight away i felt much
safer because i think one of the
problems with with all of this is that
there's been unsafe standing at football
for years
um at anfield at all premier league
grounds it's gone on particularly in in
a way sections it's just you ten you
gravitate towards standing rightly the
disaster at hillsborough in 1989 in
which 97 liverpool fans were killed made
football take a long hard look at how
supporters were treated
now nearly three decades after all sita
stadiums were introduced some experts
believe standing can actually make
things safer what we can't have is
another disaster happening and the risks
arising from people persistently
standing in seated areas that aren't
designed for those people to stand is a
real one the police say it can make
identifying troublemakers harder and
clubs have to keep fans in their
designated standing spaces we need to
monitor we need to see the impacts
we need to be evidence-led on it and if
there are issues then there'll have to
be some brave decisions about what
actually is the best thing for safety
and security
chelsea are confident it will work and
it's in two at manchester city cardiff
city manchester united and tottenham
hotspur they now just need some games to
play
tom parmenter sky news stamford bridge
now from this morning the way we buy
house and car insurance should change
significantly companies now have to
offer the same price to new as well as
existing customers and i'm joined now by
the co-founder and chief executive of
insurance firm urban jungle jimmy
williams happy new year to you jimmy i'm
not sure how many people are waking up
this morning uh thinking about insurance
but maybe they should be
yes maybe they should be thanks very
much for having me on and happy new year
g2 um yes this is the the biggest
shake-up uh of the home and motor
insurance world that that anyone can
remember
um and what's happening just sort of in
a nutshell is that insurance companies
from this morning from today
won't be able to charge you more just
for being a loyal customer they'll have
to charge you the same as a new customer
and that is a really big shake up in
terms of the way all the pricing is
going to work
is it a penalty though for current
customers just to stay as they are um
and for
new customers or is it new customers
getting a good offer when they sign up
so
historically i guess that's the way it's
been justified by a lot of these big
insurers is that it is a you know it's
an offer signing up and that's uh and
that's kind of normal across lots of
industries i guess what's unusual is
just how big those offers are so in home
insurance for example there's about a 70
discount for year one customers
which is obviously massive and what it
means is that in order to keep getting a
good deal year after year you have to
switch you have to keep switching around
you have to phone up your insurer every
year and say hey can i have the best
deal massive pain and then if you've
been a customer perhaps for longer than
two or three years that means you're way
off the best deal that you could be
having um
and you're getting really ripped off so
you know what what this should mean for
different types of customers if perhaps
you've been with the insurance company
for four or five years happy days great
news today
what it should mean is that your price
will just automatically go down uh the
next time you get you're only all
noticed fantastic um if you're a newer
customer and you switched in the last
year or two it's likely you'll see your
price go up um and you might need to get
get sort of uh get get hunting around
for a better deal
what other practices need uh tightening
up in 2022
yeah so from from our point of view
we're a challenger in the space and we
stood against uh price walking all along
and never done it ourselves so our
prices will be remaining the same uh
from today um but we've you know really
called on the fda to go to go further
than this there's lots of things in the
industry that we'd like to see change so
for example um there's still very very
high fees out there for people to pay
monthly so typically you'd have to take
out a loan with premium finance which
means you pay a lot extra maybe
sometimes 30 or 40
apr to pay monthly which is obviously
huge there are still massive
cancellation fees there's still pricing
practices that we don't approve of like
pricing on pricing people just because
the kind of job they have or what age
they are so we think there's lots more
to go in terms of making the insurance
industry fairer and we're trying to lead
the way
all right good advice jimmy williams
from urban jungle uh thank you very much
indeed thanks very much for the time
could be a new year's resolution
couldn't it uh checking out all your uh
home and that car insurance deal see if
you can do a bit better still to come
here on sky news breakfast we're going
to take a look at the first papers of
2022 with journalist and broadcaster
fedesha and also the entrepreneur kate
hardcastle join us for that in a couple
of minutes
[Music]
if you're just joining us a very happy
new year to you time to review the first
papers of 2022 and i'm joined by the
journalist and broadcaster panisha and
the entrepreneur kate hardcastle nice to
see you both again i hope you're having
lots of strong coffee um you're doing
very well so far looking wide awake
thank you pradesha um we're in a new
year but of course uh covid still hangs
over us doesn't it and the sun reporting
today actually some good news really to
to kick things off um the third jab the
booster cuts the risk of getting into
hospital by 88
yes this is very good news but it's the
front runner for some medium news and
some bad news so the result of a very
big study over the last year and a half
shows that compared to those who have
had no jabs whatsoever getting your two
jabs plus your booster puts you at 88
of uh
protection and makes sure pretty much
that hospitalization
really dying from this new omicron
variant are
very very unlikely compared to whether
you were unjabbed or not
the medium news is that some vaccination
and booster centers are reporting that
they're two-thirds empty so people have
been very good about getting their first
two jabs and then even though the big
booster rollout has been generally
successful
in some areas there's a 40 percent lack
of uptake so people are getting that
reminder text on their phone and they're
feeling that because they are already
protected they can maybe delay getting
the booster for a little while
don't do that go right ahead because and
here's the bad news the british medical
association have pointed out that 12
400 people are currently in hospital
with covid
that staff shortages and increasing
hospitalizations which are going up 73
on christmas week are going to hobble
the nhs the nhs we love so much unless
we are all careful and unless the bma
strongly hints the government brings in
further curbs or restrictions or at
least just
steps up to the plate and acknowledges
that
our sense of complacency around omicron
being less severe than delta our sense
of complacency around booster jabs and
jab number three
are
not backed up by the statistics so
there's a full range of omicron and
covid news the great thing is we're not
in the same position that we were in 18
months ago we've got the vaccines we've
got the boosters we're seeing levels of
protection ticking up as long as
everyone continues to follow
all of those additional rules as well uh
we're just going to break into the
papers thank you for that felicia we'll
come back in a moment i just want to
take you straight to cape town st
george's cathedral the funeral of
archbishop desmond tutu is beginning as
you can see mourners all gathered there
in the cathedral where he preached so
often a building that was pivotal in the
anti-apartheid movement the clergy there
taking their place as they prepare for
that funeral service to get underway we
will of course keep across that uh for
you throughout the morning
kate lots of people making their new
year's resolutions today plenty of
people will be thinking i need to do
more exercise i want to start getting
fit but if you're into swimming i'm into
swimming it's a problem sometimes
getting to a decent local pool
that's right a stark warning from swim
england today suggesting that by the end
of the decade we may lose 2 000 up to 2
000 swimming facilities across the uk
and they said that's down to a lack of
investment now a lot of these fitness
facilities had to close down due and
covered many of them didn't receive
adequate funding many of them are legacy
pools and haven't had the investment
over recent years but we know as well as
being a life-saving lesson to learn that
it's actually a really brilliant sport
very
community-based allows a lot of people a
social activity that's affordable and
multi-generationally across the
generations so i think we need to hear
this warning we need to make sure that
any element of sport isn't uh
regionalized or um
unable to be uh
past taken by any generation any
demographic so i think we need to listen
and take the warning you know we
remember we're getting the new year's
honors list here today we're listening
to it we're hearing about people like
hannah russell bethany firth who were
our paralympic swimmers who've received
the obe of course tom daley adam peter
you've been
receiving the obe today and you know
their legacies i'm sure they would admit
wouldn't be the same if it wasn't for
those pools those fitness facilities at
the very start of their careers that
enabled them
yeah well said um we haven't got long so
i just want to uh get through another
couple of stories quite quickly badisha
if that's all right and i'm afraid it's
a rather grim story that you found for
us in the independent um this stabbing
that sees london hit a grim record for
teen killings
yeah so the record for team killings
over the last year has now hit 30
because a 16 year old boy was killed in
hillington just last week an hour before
that a teenage boy was killed in croydon
i just wanted to point out there's a
very nice comment from the met police's
commander who says that these tragedies
they're not numbers they're not
statistics these are individuals who had
lives and families and so each incident
is not just a headline to be hashed and
rehashed by people who are going to say
that london's unsafe will make
stereotypes and the kinds of people who
are
affected by knife crime or gang culture
or all the rest of it it's really a
tragedy for absolutely everyone there is
no particular demographic it's what
happens when people fall down through
the cracks in society and grow up in
areas where there is an investment in
schooling sports community services so
yes it's a grim record i don't want
these teen killings to continue yeah you
make a very good point there and uh kate
let's uh have a look at the sun
golden girls betty she's died at the age
of 99 famously played rose of course
just two weeks off her 100th birthday
and the
outpourings today of tributes to this
wonderful actress very talented actress
has been fantastic also to realize just
how much she played a part in the social
side and using her platform she had her
own tv show at a very early age and gave
the opportunity to a black dancer called
arthur duncan who uh completely
suggested it was down to betty pushing
him forward giving him that platform on
national television that helped him in
his career and so many others i will say
two things only first and foremost what
we hear today is that betty white feels
that she received the accolades in her
time it's not someone that we're doing
posthumously we are actually having to
we're acknowledging someone who actually
heard the prayers which is so so
important and number two just if you
haven't watched the accommodate re-watch
it she was the master the mistress of
which she really was we've been playing
some clips this morning uh kate badisha
thank you both very much great to see
you we'll speak again in half an hour
you